une vingtaine de personnes squatter ses
locaux dans le 9e arrondissement de Lyon
certains y exercer même une activité il
réparait des voitures la société
propriétaire engage l'année dernière une
procédure d'expulsion mais la justice
décide que les squatteurs sont autorisés
à rester jusqu'au 31 mars soit à la fin
de la trêve hivernale or le 23 janvier
la propriétaire fait changer les
serrures de désoccupants l'attaque alors
en justice mardi le tribunal leur a
donné en partie gain de cause et la
société est condamnée à leur verset 2000
euros chacun de dommages et intérêts
pour les avoir fait partir trop tôt
alors voilà question pour Gilles je
pense que la justice a très bien jugé
il faut savoir que c'est pas une
propriétaire qui pouvait plus rentrer
chez une société qui a acheté ça il y a
2 ans et demi pour faire de la gestion
les deux squats en question c'est un
serrurier une enseignante et c'est vrai
que il devait partir le 31 mars et je ne
sais pas pourquoi ils ont changé les
serrures ça s'appelle une violation de
domicile parce que la justice avait
tranchée donc ils ont été attaqués ils
ont perdu et ils doivent verser 6000
euros
tu me connais je suis extrêmement
légaliste et effectivement on ne peut
pas mettre les gens dehors après avant
la fin de la trêve hivernale mais la
reconnaît malgré tout qu'on met sur le
même plan des squatteurs et des gens qui
ont parfois des problèmes ponctuels liés
à la société à la situation parce que il
y a l'inflation etc juste ponctuellement
ou pas là en l'occurrence ce sont des
gens qui ont squatté qui n'étaient pas
dans par exemple un locataire qui
ponctuellement un problème et qui dit à
son propriétaire là pendant un mois ou
deux je vais avoir des petits soucis
pardonnez-moi et puis je te parle
des squatteurs chez lui
non mais moi moi je vais vous dire moi
je deviens fou en ce moment et qu'est-ce
qui se passe en français on devient fou
non mais les mecs c'est on marche sur la
tête mature c'est pas ce que tu en
penses
il y a une France des bobos je vois des
articles des choses des mecs qui sont
complètement à côté de la plaque qui ne
connaissent rien en français qui ne
connaît sur rien la France qui donne
leur avis qui nous envoie dans le mur je
vous dis la vérité qui nous envoie dans
le mur et c'est cette France et qui qui
est gouverné depuis des années par ces
gens qui nous envoient dans le mur c'est
c'est c'est voilà et je vois cette
presse je vois encore religion encore vu
libération là mais c'est aberrant mais
c'est c'est aberrant ils sont à côté de
la plaque ils sont dans leur ils sont au
Café de Flore dans le 6e en train de
prendre des des des des des des des
entrain de prendre des thés des thés à
la menthe j'ai rien contre le café de
feu en plus c'est super il y avait
dedans mais c'est la clé la LC ces
gens-là c'est une expression voilà voilà
ils sont complètement hors-sol et qui
voit que aujourd'hui il ferait mieux de
s'occuper au lieu de s'occuper de de
faire des articles sur Sofia Aram euh il
doit défendre sophiaram qui ne sert à
rien je suis désolé qu'il fasse des
articles pour essayer de défendre les
agriculteurs qui fasse des articles pour
essayer de les infirmières qui fassent
des articles pour essayer de faire
avancer les choses sur ces lois qui sont
complètement
désuètes maintenant et qui sont
du courage pour ça pour écrire sur
sofiara mais Cyril Hanouna il y a du
monde mais tout le monde s'en fout hein
je vous le dis c'est pas pour ça que
vous allez vendre plus de papier la
presse est morte et je vous le dis vous
aussi donc je vous dis ça sert à rien
d'écrire sur ça écrivez plutôt au plus
haut servez-vous de vos votre torchon
pour essayer d'aider les Français au
lieu de de vous dire des articles de
merde
merci non moi c'est il y a il y a deux
choses qui sont il y a deux choses qui
te dérangent pas sur ce du squat mais
plus généralement par exemple quand tu
disais il faut accueillir des Syriens et
tout ça bien sûr qu'on a un cœur le
problème tu reparlé c'est que quand on
accueille ils vont pas habiter dans le
Marais près de chez toi ou dans ma rue
on les met toujours au même endroit
c'est-à-dire chez les gens qui n'ont
rien qui n'ont pas d'argent c'est c'est
eux qui accueillent ces gens-là et nous
on donne des grandes leçons à table pour
dire il faut il faut il faut ça c'est
vrai le problème et le deuxième la
deuxième chose que j'aimerais dire parce
que hier je lui effectivement les
articles sur Sophia Aram et tout ça
en tout cas Mathieu tu es le seul à lire
parce que plus personne
je voudrais juste dire un petit truc
après tu vas le dire à Dieu c'est que ne
croyez pas que la presse va faire des
bons articles sur nous et demi tous les
soirs ils sont énervés comme tout on
fait ils vendent qu'ils vendent 40 000
au maximum c'est catastrophique ce qui
se passe pour eux donc ils essaient de
faire du buzz sur nous et sachez-le avec
ce qu'on leur met dans la gueule tous
les jours forcément ils vont pas faire
des bons articles sur nous mais sachez
c'est pas parce qu'ils font des articles
qu'on va tourner notre veste et qu'on va
dire du bien d'eux hein je vais vous
dire pour moi c'est des torchons ça
restera des torchons oui on dit parfois
des bêtises on sait pas tout sur tout
mais les gens qui commentent de la de
perdre un tapis et les gens qui font par
exemple ce qu'on a fait hier que je fais
ruber je suis très triste pour ce
monsieur qui a été licencié mais j'ai
pris un uber ce matin qui m'a dit
maintenant on est comme ça on sait que
si on déconne et tout ça on peut être
licencié voilà en un truc on a fait en
sorte que les chauffeurs vont bien se
comporter maintenant avec les handicapés
avec les yeux il a pas fait un qui finir
Dylan avec voilà ce que je veux dire on
fait ce qu'on peut mais on essaie d'agir
alors on se trompe parfois on n'a pas
tous nous on fait bouger les choses
à écrire trois conneries et être tout
content d'avoir fait 150 vues côté moi
bien eux ils iront pas bien loin je vous
le dis c'est eux qui nous et je vous le
dis et je le redis ce sont ces gens-là
qui envoie la France dans le mur je vous
le dis si on est dans une situation
comme ça aujourd'hui ils sont très très
ils ont une très grande part de
responsabilité sachez-le et je pense
qu'on fait beaucoup plus pour la France
bien sûr que tous ces
grades papier qui ne font que mettre de
l'huile sur le feu moi je me rappelle
des gilet jaune moi je vais vous donner
un exemple sur les gilets jaunes sur les
gilets jaunes qui s'écars sur les gilets
jaunes ici
et non et qui c'est qui a défoncé les
gilets contre c'est Sofia RAM qui a
défoncé le peuple je vous le dis tous
les soirs tous les jours elle faisait
des chroniques sur des gilets jaunes les
des cérébrés les abrutis qui étaient
dans la rue pendant qu'elle était en
train de prendre des Verts au Café de
Flore avec ses amis je leur dis quoi
mais c'est pour faire de la pub parce
qu'ils sont sympas le café dehors non
mais je vous le dis Non Non mais au-delà
de ça qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait elle pour
les gens elle fait rien pour les gens je
vous dis les gilets jaunes les gilets
jaunes c'est quoi les gilets jaunes
c'était juste des gens qui se
plaignaient et qui en avait marre et
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe actuellement
c'est juste c'est ça c'est c'est la
continuité des vélos ils avaient juste
prévenu euh que ça allait se passer
comme ça mais eux ils sont dans leur
action 61 ils sont contents ils font
leur petite chronique ils font rire
trois personnes trois bobos qui sont
contents avec leur mocassins Minelli et
ils vont arrêter de nous faire chier non
mais je vous le dis ouais non mais c'est
vrai
après
après je vais vous dire et ne croyez pas
que la presse va encore reprendre la ce
que j'ai dit demain et on va dire j'en
ai rien à [__] mais franchement
je vais vous dire je suis bien plus
heureux que moi je fais ma vie je fais
mes trucs je les compte pas
très bien leur travail hein j'en connais
je connais voilà mais c'est vrai que il
y en a beaucoup et de plus en plus ce
sont eux je vous dis sur les gilets
jaunes qui c'est qui mettaient de
l'huile sur le feu toute la semaine hein
et qui disait et qui faisait que le
samedi et le dimanche ça se passait
parfois mal le le samedi et ben je vous
dis c'est toujours les mêmes je suis
désolé excusez-moi de vous dire ça non
mais excusez-moi de vous dire ça et
ouais qui c'est qui fait des des
articles sur la police et raciste
comment vous voulez qu'un policier le
lendemain il a arrêté quelqu'un dans la
dans la dans voilà tranquillement et que
la personne va l'écouter il a vu un
reportage pendant deux heures sur la
police et raciste vous êtes marrant vous
moi je vous racontez un une anecdote tu
vois que j'ai jamais raconté un jour
j'ai le j'ai le bah je vous le dire j'ai
j'ai le président qui m'appelle
comme ça il est président il appelle ce
qu'on était sur un truc qu'on devait ou
de faire une émission ensemble et je lui
ai donné cet exemple je lui ai dit
comment vous pouvez laisser passer
excusez-moi dis-moi je m'occupe pas il
m'a dit moi je laisse passer moi je suis
pour la liberté d'expression c'est très
bien y aller il m'a dit moi quand je
vois un reportage de 2h sur la police et
raciste je suis désolé les mecs il y a
des on peut pas dire que la police il y
a des il y a dans toutes les cordes de
métier il y a des brebis galeuses dans
tout même en télé dans la vie voilà mais
dans la vie exactement dans la vie pour
moi il y a les cons et s'il y a le reste
c'est tout quand tu es raciste tu es con
bah voilà c'est tout mais voilà mais
c'est pas euh on est pas là-dedans mais
tu vois et le patron de Gilles Mélenchon
qui dit il y a trop de sirène de police
la lune dans Paris
franchement arrêtez c'est je vous dis et
là en ce moment il y a un cas où et ils
sont énormément responsables donc au
lieu d'écrire sur des articles de merde
sur comment défendre Sofia RAM parce que
je vous dis c'est toute une ils se
tiennent tous les tiens tout ça entre
parce que voilà c'est tout voilà la même
corporation ah nous on est un petit peu
à part donc forcément je vous dis voilà
il ferait mieux d'écrire comment se
comment s'en sortir pour les
agriculteurs comment s'en sortir pour
les chauffeurs uber comment s'en sortir
aujourd'hui pour plein de sociétés qui
qui c'est joli la situation économique
et de plus en plus grave et comment s'en
sortir pour des gens qui travaillent 8
10 heures par jour et qui arrive pas à
s'en sortir qui donne des vrais
solutions pour faire décrire les voir
les gens parce que je l'ai lu des
horreurs sur vous elle dit Cyril et sa
bande de cons il y a pas d'accord
quand génitaux
qui me choque qui me paraissent très
graves la première c'est que tu dis
Gilles oui mais c'est une société de
gestionnaire à propos des squatteurs
c'est une société de gestionnaire de
bien c'est ça sous-entendu c'est des
nantir
les petites retraites
un peu pour s'arranger avec des petites
économies donc
tu as toujours fait du racisme anti
riche je te le dis toujours ça c'est
insupportable
parce qu'on est retraité qu'on a vu de
l'argent de côté qu'on arrive à se payer
un petit appartement et au bout de sa
vie je veux dire c'est pas pour ça qu'on
y arrive on doit pas on doit pas se
faire cracher dessus quand même et avoir
des squatteurs chez soi le racisme
anti-rise pour moi c'est anti-riche
c'est exactement comme les autres formes
du tout hein
c'est pas ça vas-y Jean-Luc moi quand je
vois ça moi Jean-Luc non moi quand je
vois ce résultat là en fait ça me donne
une sorte de défiance envers la justice
et le problème de la défiance envers la
justice c'est qu'on a plus confiance en
la justice et que donc les gens vont
justice eux-mêmes tu comprends et en
fait moi je voudrais qu'il y a une
justice qui soit cohérente et quand je
vois que
c'est visiblement parce que elle est
condamnée
qui ont fait justice le même en
changeant la serrure
protège pas la justice ne s'arrête pas
ils ont changé seulement la serrure
c'est quand même un truc de fou mais
c'est chez toi tu changes de la serrure
un peu écouter un peu le bon sens bien
sûr comment tu peux être condamné quand
tu fais cesser quelque chose d'illégal
tu as fait si c'est quelque chose
et les squatteurs réclamait même leur
réintégration dans les locaux ça c'est
le pompon ils veulent les boulets qu'on
les réinte dans les locaux et la société
leur réclamait
il y a pas un Français qui défend les
squatteurs sont les quatre paupérisation
totale on l'a dit une famille
pour les squatteurs elle est elle est
elle est bien comme elle a dit Valérie
tout à l'heure quelqu'un qui est en
galère qui peut pas payer son loyer qui
a des enfants ok pour l'hiver en hiver
tu le vires pas tu sais tu as la loi la
trêve comme on dit tu le laisses chez
lui il y a pas de problème et il règlera
son histoire mais des gars qui rentrent
comme ça on infraction chez quelqu'un
qui s'empare des lieux et qui sont tu
changes la serrure et on te condamne
mais qui a fait la première infraction
la première attraction a été faite par
les squatteurs mais bien sûr 2000 euros
d'amende au
squatteurs
ils ont tout cas moi je vais rentrer
dans une maison au mois de fin octobre
début novembre et je vais la garder tout
l'hiver
qui a des bobos qui vont faire un
article sur toi demain qui va dire ouais
tu as vu il veut mettre le squatteur
dehors mais je te dis regarde tu leur
diras que oui les squatteurs qui sont
rentrés illégalement dans une dans le
bien de quelqu'un qui a travaillé toute
sa vie pour la voix
du cas présent tu n'as jamais une
solution à proposer
je te promets donne pas de leçon je lui
donne pas de leçon à chaque fois tu dis
c'est ça c'est ça quand tu dis qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire tu n'as jamais une
solution jamais là il y a eu un jugement
on considère ici on veut dire que le
jugement est injuste je pense qu'il y a
énormément de français je sais pas si on
un sondage je pense qu'il y a énormément
voilà de je vous dis de personnes qui
pensent encore le contraire de toi je
vois il y a des gens qui dit Gilles
gagnent je sais pas combien d'euros par
mois ils disent 20000 €, je pense pas
mais bon je le ferai habite dans Paris
il donne et il donne des leçons à ceux
qui galèrent voilà ce que dit les gens
là est-ce qu'ils sont en
infractions est-ce qu'ils sont en France
ils viennent d'être condamnés est-ce
qu'ils sont en infraction non plus
maintenant non c'est ça
alors pourquoi tu condames quelqu'un qui
est rentré chez toi par le fraction tu
connais pas
j'ai très bien compris ce qu'il a dit et
il pense comme tout l'ensemble des
Français ce soir une fois de plus c'est
incroyable d'entendre ça et je vous dis
c'est c'est une France qui me rend fou
seulement et en ce moment on se dit on
est je vous dis quand on fait cette
émission et merci d'être de plus en plus
nombreux à regarder je pense que c'est
aussi pour ça parce que vous dites c'est
vrai qu'ici et je je le dis mon analyse
je pense qu'on est une des seules
missions à dire vraiment la vérité et à
traiter vraiment des sujets voilà je
vous le dis c'est on marche sur la tête
en ce moment quelle émission va traiter
de ça et qui va dire ça ils vont le
faire quand nous on se sera fait
défoncer par tout le monde ils vont le
faire derrière non mais derrière ils
vont le faire
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dit ils ont dit
nous on te suit on a juste à regarder on
attend que tu foutes le bordel et nous
on suit pas on est derrière toi tu
donnes le tempo et moi j'ai mais c'est
ouf les deux grands journalistes qui
sont en train de dire que c'est toi qui
donne le tempo ça veut dire nous on
vient on prend les coups on se fait
accusé derrière et eux sont derrière et
bah maintenant qu'il l'a fait maintenant
qu'ils ont parlé mais tu as raison on
continue à le faire juste on va voir le
sondage tiens là-dessus parce que c'est
incroyable voilà bah merci merci bonne
journée
a priori ils sont d'accord avec nous
[Applaudissements]
après Cyril il faut il faut rappeler
qu'on est le seul pays d'Europe ou
encore est-ce que
voilà voilà
[Musique]
un pays un pays qui n'a plus de justice
ça s'appelle l'anarchie aujourd'hui on
est obligé de se défendre tout seul
c'est exactement la faute à qui est-ce
les gens sont en train de s'armer tu te
rends compte de ça les gens sont en
train de s'aimer les gens ont peur ils
vont pas prendre ça attention attention
si moi je sors déjà j'ai investi c'est
moi qui vais payer pour changer de
source pour des connards qui sont
rentrés chez moi et en plus tu veux quoi
derrière jusqu'au 31 mars toujours en
train de se dire qu'il faut pas se faire
juste histoire un peu Gilles juste sur
le fait que c'est pas non mais
très mauvaise émission ça fait très
mauvaise émission
c'est ma première et ma dernière du coup
je pense que oui
je rejoins un peu Gilles juste sur le
fait que le débat c'est pas sur le squat
on est tous d'accord que on n'est pas si
on n'est pas ok pour que les gens
squattent mais en revanche ne pas se
faire juste toi-même là ils ont juste
changé
la police
là ils ont juste changé les serrures
mais si demain il y a un four qui te met
un gun sur la tête pour pouvoir rentrer
chez toi ça prend des proportions
énormissime
que quelqu'un chez toi tu fais quoi tu
attends le 31 mars
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
justice eux-mêmes et dans ce cas-là il
faut durcir la loi contre les oiseaux
tout est fait pour les délinquants dans
ce pays tout est fait pour les gens qui
ne travaillent pas que ce soit les aides
que ce soit tout est fait pour ces
gens-là mettre les ailes en question
absolument je t'ai dit quand j'ai vu ici
une fois le face à Baba avec une vieille
dame une personne âgée pardon qui disait
qu'elle gagnait 1200 euros elle
travaillait à travailler toute sa vie et
que les gens qui n'ont jamais travaillé
en 920 euros de retraite 200 euros
d'écart entre les gens qui ont travaillé
et qui ne font rien oui ce pays aide les
gens qui ne travaillent pas
tout c'est pas toi qui va me dire ça
pardon quand
tu parleras dans le pré mais oh Castaldi
tu parleras de la mort est dans le pré
ah oui ça c'est moi
alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a il met le
doigt sur un truc qui tombe pas des
Français oui la première fois qu'il me
doit pas le dire parce que c'est facile
de dire moi je vais aider tout le monde
je vais aider tout le monde on est tout
le monde avec les impôts des Français et
bien le doigt sur quelque chose qui
tombe pas rond moi ma maman a fait 912 €
de retraite tant mieux moi je viens je
fais ce que je peux mais tu as des gens
qui ont jamais bossé qui font 3004 qui
ont jamais versé 1 € d'impôts à la
France il met le doigt sur quelque chose
sur un moment donné il faudra changer ce
système quand on pleure qu'on dit qu'on
a pas d'argent ou on va trouver l'argent
bah faut faire travailler les gens plus
longtemps et ben il faut faire
travailler les éboueurs plus longtemps à
un moment donné remettez les sous
remettez la tête dans les comptes et
dites-vous bien qu'il y a des gens qui
ont pas versé 1 € d'impôts bien sûr
qu'on jamais travaillé une seule journée
qui font du Black toute la journée et
qui prennent des mille balles 1200
balles d'aides et quelqu'un qui a
travaillé 35 ans 37 ans va faire 815 €
de retard c'est pas normal ça c'est mort
des aides
c'est Mathieu et je vais vous dire et ça
tu vas voir toi tu vas un article de moi
j'ai écouté les gens est-ce qu'on s'en
fout de se faire massacrer je voudrais
juste dire au téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent arrêtez de croire tout ce qui
est écrit dans les journaux je vous le
dis c'est il y a énormément de conneries
et jolie je suis bien placé pour le
savoir c'est vous sur les carrières ou
les ou les femmes elles ont eu besoin
d'élever leurs enfants pendant 7-8 ans
10 ans parce qu'elles avaient trois
quatre enfants elles ont arrêté de
travailler et là elles ont travaillé 30
ans au lieu de 40 ou 42 il a raison elle
touche 800 balles et le voisin à côté
bah moi j'ai jamais travaillé de ma vie
pourquoi pourquoi tu veux que j'aille
travailler je fais 1000 2 aujourd'hui je
vais travailler pour 1003 pour 100
balles je vais payer mon passe Navigo je
vais payer la bouffe le midi je reste
chez moi ça tombe vas-y toi travaillé
pour moi
d'accord
et un jour je donc il y a un certain
montant et un jour je vais voir le
chômage et je dis bah c'est cool j'ai
trouvé des extraits à côté et la fille
me dit bah je serai vous je les prendrai
pas
donc c'est ce qu'on me demandait et
pardon j'en ai profité donc oui j'étais
un gros con j'étais plus jeune on me
demandait de prouver que on refusait de
m'engager c'est alors j'envoyais des
lettres à la con à des grosses grosses
boîtes en disant je vais être directeur
financier ben non monsieur vous appelez
le niveau alors je montrais mes lettres
que c'était pas possible et je touchais
de l'argent tous les mois ça a duré 2
ans et demi j'étais chômeur 2 ans et
demi si vous exploitez le système c'est
de la faute de personne si mais à votre
plein
de possibilité à des gens de gagner de
l'argent moi le premier sans travailler
on apprend c'est quoi tes solutions
mais pourquoi vous me demandez ça je
suis pas en politique ni élu etc moi je
m'en orgueille je m'en orgueille de
payer des impôts pour aider des gens qui
souffrent qui n'ont pas de travail qui
bénéficient d'aide sociale
mais tout le monde le dit ça tout le
monde est d'accord
il dit il dit que des gens profitent du
système moi je m'en orgueille que des
étrangers qui n'ont rien
même s'il veut aller dans son sens moi
je vais te le dire à un moment donné moi
un moment donné j'ai vu mes voisins
restez chez eux payer la cantine 50
centimes il travaillait pas j'ai
pourquoi tu mettais pourquoi tu mets ton
enfant à la cantine tu travailles pas il
me dit mais qu'est-ce que tu veux que
j'aille le mettre à la cantine parce que
des mecs comme moi payent 5 € de cantine
pendant que toi tu mets pas ton enfer en
réalité c'est que j'aime pas dans la vie
facilement
ok Google